support vector machine is one of the
past and nonlinear supervised - machine
learning models given a set of labeled
training data SVM will help us to find
the optimum hyperplane which categorized
new examples in 1 dimensional space the
hyperplane is a point in two dimensional
space the hyperplane is a land and in
three-dimensional space the hyperplane
is a surface that divides a space into
two parts where each class lies on
either side in the first section of this
video we are going to go through the
detailed process of finding the optimum
hyperplane let's first start with the
two dimensional linear separable case
figure Y ensures that the data are
separated by a line in this case the
data are linearly separable figure two
is an example of non linearly separable
data which means that we can now define
a line to separate the data therefore we
say the data are linearly separable if
we can find a line to separate the
original data let's have a closer look
at figure one in general there are lots
of possible solutions for drawing a
hyperplane to separate the positive
samples from the negative samples but
which one is the best SVM can help us
choose the best hyperplane which
maximizes the margin or sometimes we
call it a street around the hyperplane
to separate as a positive ones from the
negative ones that's the reason why
sometimes we also call SVM the maximum
margin classifier now let's introduce
another important concept support
vectors support vectors are the data
points that lie closest to the
hyperplane they are the data points most
difficult to classify which also decide
which hyperplane we should choose
unlike some other Michelini models like
linear regression on your network which
all data points influence the final
optimization for SVM only the difficult
points which is the support vectors has
an impact on the final decision boundary
moving a support vectors move the
decision boundary moving the other
vectors has no impact just like any
other muscle in your model during the
inference time as VM will predict the
output Y with input X the input is just
a set of features X for each sample SVM
will help us to find a set of weights W
for each feature then through the linear
combination of input features and
weights we can predict the output Y so
far it is just like the neural net
however there is a major difference SVM
will optimize the weights in such a way
that the only support vectors determines
weights and the decision boundary now
that starts the fun part of this section
we're going to go through the underlying
mathematical process finds VM to find
the hyperplane and maximum the margin
this part only requires that you have
some basic background of linear algebra
and optimization Theory still for this
2d example we have three important lines
the middle line of the street h0 which
is the hyperplane two gutters of the
straight h1 and h2 now let's assume
there is a vector W perpendicular to
these three lines for all the points on
h0 they should have the same projection
distance on w direction which is w
dotted x over the magnitude of W is
equal to say let's multiply the
magnitude of W on each set of the
equation we can obtain W dot 8x is equal
to say times the magnitude of W now
let's substitute se times the magnitude
of W with negative B we can get the
function of the land h0 as W dotted ax
plus B is equal to zero which is the
equation for H zero
here we only have two dimensions so this
can be expanded as a following function
in fact this expression works for any
number of dimensions once we have the
expression of hyperplane we can then use
it to make predictions for this example
if the expression for any unknown sample
is equal or greater than zero will
predict it as a positive sample
otherwise we predict all know as
negative similarly we can write the
expression for garter h1 and h2 here K
is just another constant value and we
can rescale W and B to make K is equal
to 1 for mathematical convenience as we
have introduced before SVM is a maximum
margin classifier to find a way to
express a margin or street weights here
let's introduce two vectors 1 X negative
2 an active sample on the garda h2
another 1 x+ to an appositive sample on
the gara each one now let's take the
difference of these two vectors and dot
product is with the unit vector
perpendicular to h0 we can get an
expression of the ways of the street
from previous draft function for gather
h1 and h2 we can get w dotted x+ it's
equal to 1 minus b for the positive
sample and w dotted x- is equal to
negative 1 minus p for negative sample
let's substitute them back to the
straight weights equation and derive 8
as 2 over the magnitude of W in order to
maximize this ways with us need to
minimize the magnitude of W for
mathematical convenience it is
equivalent to minimize 1/2 times the
magnitude of W squared which also
equivalent to 1/2 times w dot e 2w
however we cannot make this straight
with arbitrary large we can only expand
the street weights under the condition
that there are no data points between
each one and
to mathematically this means for all the
positive samples they should obey the
constraint the WX plus B is greater or
equal to 1 and for all the negative
samples the constraint is doublet ax
plus B is less or equal than negative 1
now let's introduce another variable Y
to transform these two equations to make
it more convenient from mathematical
perspective here we assume Y to be 1 for
all positive samples and negative 1 for
all negative samples so the previous two
equations can be rewritten as a single
equation for all the samples let's
revisit the problems we're trying to
solve here we want to optimize the
street weights 1/2 times W dotted W
subjected to the constraint equation for
all the samples it is a constrained
optimization problems and we have a
powerful technique lagrangian multiplier
for this if you are going to find an
extreme of a function with constraint
then we are going to have to use
Lagrangian multipliers this will give us
some new expressions using which we can
find the optimization of 8 without
thinking about the constraints anymore
for this problem the new expression can
be written as one half times the WTTW
manners the summation of all the
constraints and each of the constraints
is going to have a multiplier alpha sub
I what we are going to do next is to
find an extremum of this new expression
well for this we just need to find all
the derivatives of this expression and
set them to 0 the first equation is a
partial derivative of L the Lagrangian
with respect to the vector tableau after
setting it to 0 we can get to the W
equals to the summation of alpha sub I
times y sub I times X sub I over I for
all the samples this is very interesting
it tells us the vector W can be obtained
with a linear sum of the sample
of actors actually at the end of the
optimization a lot of alpha-i is going
to be 0 and the non 0 alpha I respond to
the samples in the gutter which is the
support vectors now we should
differentiate the Lagrangian with
respect to B as well which is going to
be equal to the sum of alpha sub I times
y sub I also at the extremum condition
it should be equal to 0 now we are going
to plug the derived expression W back in
the Lagrangian equation and the magic
happens here we can merge the first two
term and the second term and rewrite the
equation as a following one what we've
discovered is that the optimization
depends only on the dot product of pairs
of samples now we can also substitute
u2w back to the decision rule which is
going to be sum of alpha sub I times y
sub I times X sub I taught it to the
unknown vector u plus B if that is
greater or equal to 0 then the
prediction is a positive sample now we
discovered that the decision rule also
depends only on the dot product of those
samples vectors with the arno vector our
previous discussion is based on the
assumption that the samples are linearly
separable and there is no outliers in
the data and above SVM formulation is
called hot margin SVM what if there are
some noise and outlier in the data set
then the heart margin SVM simply cannot
tolerate them and the field to find the
optimization let's revisit our
inequality constraint here for the
optimization problem to be solved all
the constraints have to be satisfied in
this part we will talk about how to deal
with this limitation using soft margin
SVM
basically the trick is very simple let's
add a slack variable Zeta to the
constraint of the optimization problem
it now becomes this equation with theta
by adding these slack variables we're
minimizing the objective function it is
not possible to satisfy the constraint
even if some outliers do not meet the
original constraint the problem is we
can always choose a large enough value
of data so that all examples will
satisfy the constraints one technique to
handle this problem is to use regular
addition for example we could use l1
regulation to penalize the large value
of theta now the regularized
optimization problem becomes the
following expression notice that the
Zeta here is always a positive number
and the regularization parameter C
determines how important data should be
which means how much we want to avoid
misclassifying each training example a
smaller C emphasized the importance of
Zeta and a larger Z diminishes the
importance of data if we set say to
positive infinite we will get the same
optimization result at the heart margin
SVM so small values of C will result in
a wider margin at the cost of some
misclassifications large value of C will
result in the smaller margin at a less
tolerant to outliers now the soft margin
SVM can handle the non linearly
separable data with some outliers and
noise what if the non linearly separable
data is not caused by the noise what if
the data are characteristically non
linearly separable like the following
case in this part we will talk about a
technique called
kernel trick to deal with this kind of
problem for this example it looks like
there is no easy way to draw a line to
separate the positive samples from the
negative samples
however if we transform the data from
one space to another space we would be
able to find a hyperplane to separate
the data now let's revisit our
Lagrangian we find that the optimization
only depends on the dot product of the
sample AK sub I and the sub J so we
could use any transformation function
that can be expressed at the dot product
of X sub I and X sub J we call this
function kernel function so the kernel
trick is to define a kernel function k
and use it to replace the X sub I dotted
X sub J in the Lagrangian this is a
small but powerful trick for these
problems we could try to the kernel as X
1 sub I square plus X 2 sub I squared if
we plot these samples in the new space a
clear separation is visible and the line
can be drawn to separate the positive
samples from the negative samples here I
will also show two popular kernels
polynomial kernel and RBF kernel the
polynomial kernel is defined as the
following expression this kernel
contains two parameters a constant C and
the degree of freedom D a larger value
of T will make the decision boundary
more complex and Matt resort in
overfitting the RBF kernel is defined as
the following expression the RBF kernel
is also called Gaussian kernel it will
result in a more complex Gaussian
boundary it has one parameter gamma here
are some examples for SVM with RBF
kernel of different gamma values the
simulation is now with second learn a
small value of gamma will make the model
behave like a linear SVM without kernel
a large value of gamma will make the
model heavily impacted by the support
factors and may result in overfitting I
hope you like this video don't forget to
subscribe to us and the rain the
notification bell and stay tuned